hey dr. Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about how to change your
thought to change your shape we have
these positive affirmations here I have
a little link below you can download
them and post them on your wall and read
them over and over and over again so
let's just kind of go through these are
these are different viewpoints that you
want to start shifting some of the
self-talk that you are doing maybe
unknowingly or you're unaware of it
number one if I crave I find the reason
there's always a cause for your cravings
so I don't expect you to do any program
with cravings it's impossible if you do
a program and you get rid of cravings
it's going to be a lot easier especially
long-term the next one if weight loss is
slow I cried my health very simple
weight loss is created through focusing
on creating health weight is a symptom
of an unhealthy body so if you just can
just each day start doing actions to
create your health you will lose the
weight that happens every single time
now eating for health keeps me out of
trouble again most people eat for
pleasure
that puts them in trouble I had a guy
come over the last week his whole focus
him and his wife they've been living it
up the good life for the last 20 years
going out eating whatever they want well
it finally caught up with them as a
fatty liver he has a lot of liver issues
and so does she
so now they have to make up the damage
so really what we want to do is eat for
health but you know what most people
don't change until they have a health
problem so I'm going to suggest you
learn from the mistakes of others and
don't wait until you have a health
problem I am in total control of my
eating that is a very positive thing to
say versus you know I'm out of control
you know you control your eating so
that's a good affirmation I won't start
if I stop eating so when you're full all
you have to do is stop people are not
starving in Russia or whatever in China
like your parents used to tell you so
that's not really current you don't to
worry about that people won't starve if
you you know don't eat everything on
your plate so I always like to
make sure that I put in my plate I don't
just like fill it up huge I just make
sure I put a smaller amount because I do
have a tendency to have to eat
everything in my plate but I just have
to just be aware that I don't have to
eat everything on my plate I can stop
eating when I'm full it's okay all right
next one I built self-discipline through
consistency so you actually build
yourself up through winning and saying
no to this over and over again staying
consistent eventually you will have a
very strong discipline if you don't if
you give in to something oh my gosh it
weakens you over and over and over and
over so stay consistent I only put
healthy things in my body right so just
focus on that that's a very good healthy
thing to do I can lose weight as I get
healthy so again don't focus on the
weight loss focus on the health and the
weight loss comes off as a gradual
consequence of getting healthy it's kind
of a redundant one to this one over here
but I just want to put it in there to
you know stick it in there all right if
things don't work I find out why so
here's the thing there's always a reason
there's always a reason why you might
not be losing I'll give you an example
some people are not losing because
they're gaining and healing their muscle
density that has to heal before they can
even lose weight some people they have
to fix the sleep before they lose weight
some people have to get healthy and that
means that fix the liver or these other
body issues before they lose the way so
just try to stand back and go you know
what why there's must be a reason why
I'm not losing weight and don't give up
search for it
try to understand the problem deeper
next one if things get complex I
simplified anything complex is a lie
everything that's simple tends to be
truthful so I always like to break this
down into the smallest component part
okay I have a salad over there I put it
in my mouth I chew it I eat it that
creates health okay oh I just keep it
really really basic all the time I have
this list one late older I eat some kale
she's like well when do I have to eat it
do I have to cook it what about if it's
not raw what do I have to spice it do it
no that's complex just eat it you know
keep it simple trying to be so complex
about it all right
overwhelmed means I need to plan more
there's a hidden step with losing weight
and that has to do with the
organizational step or planning step
before you even do the actions of losing
weight especially when it comes down to
eating you have to plan the whole week
out very important not just jump in
there and start doing it the more
planning the more simple steps when you
plan you have to put really small little
baby steps in sequence and focus on the
doing this so everything's planned out
for the week so you don't catch yourself
Wednesday like starving and having to go
to McDonald's so you want to plan more
especially if you get overwhelmed
keep it simple as well okay when tempted
I find a substitute now there's certain
things that you go you gravitate to
maybe ice cream or bread or chocolate
whatever make sure those foods are in
your house but a substitute version of
them they have chocolate with stevia we
have recipes on the site for all sorts
of cookies there's a pizza recipe I'm
going to come up with an ice cream
alternative recipe there's ice cream at
the store that you can get that has no
sugar there's so many alternatives
you've got to focus on the substitutes
for the things that you really gravitate
to all right last one I'm not a victim
I'm cause I caused my health so
basically if you keep that that's like
the most important one you cause your
health if you have a health problem or
if you have a weight problem look at it
from the viewpoint of there's something
I must have done or something that
happened to me that created this I don't
just end up like this overnight because
that empowers you because if you are a
victim of something then you can't do
anything about it because this other
thing over here is causing the problem
take full responsibility for your own
health and you will be empowered by
doing that so download this this little
one pager and read it every single day
you